عيسى كما تعلم احنا الان نتحدث عن
الوساطات القطريه التي تمتد لاكثر من 25
عاما قطر تراكمت لديها خبره حقيقه في هذا
المجال ومسيره ناجحه من عدد كبير من
الوساطات التي تمت وبالتالي هذه المرونه
وهذه الخبره التي تكونت لدى قطر تم
استثمارها في هذا الملف وحقيقه من اهم
اسباب نجاح هذه الوساطه كان حرص كل
الاطراف على ان يضعوا الاطفال في مركز هذه
العمليه ومصلحه الاطفال في مركز هذه
العمليه وقدره قطر على ان تثبت نفسها
كوسيط وكشريك موثوق به في مجال صناعه
السلام عالميا هو ما اكسبها هذه الثقه في
هذه الوساطه نتمنى ان تكون هذه الوساطه
بابا لمزيد من النجاحات في هذا الملف بين
روسيا واوكرانيا ولكن ايضا ان ينعكس ذلك
على بقيه الوساطات التي تعمل فيها قطر هذه
الايام فهذه ليست الوساطه الوحيده المنخرط
فيها قطر حاليا ونامل ان نرى طبعا تطورات
ايجابيه في الملفات الاخرى